[Music]
the virtue noble disaster of 1986 marked
the beginning of the end for the Soviet
Union suddenly even the communist elites
didn't trust the system mikhail
gorbachev stated that it was too noble
and not perestroika that led to the
Soviet collapse
thirty years later Iran accidentally
shot down a Ukrainian plane suddenly
even the strongest supporters of the
ayatollahs were ashamed thousands of
people had protested against the regime
and this leads visual politic to wonder
to what extent are we looking at the
Iranian version of Chernobyl what is
really going on in the Islamic Republic
of Iran well we're gonna tell you all
about it in this video so let's get into
it
[Applause]
Iran is a fragmented country on the one
hand the economy keeps going from bad to
worse Iranians are suffering from
double-digit inflation there are food
shortages for basic items and the only
thing on the rise is unemployment
[Music]
however beyond its borders the Iranian
Empire is undergoing one of its best
errors surprisingly Iran has a huge
influence on the region check out this
map
[Music]
the countries such as Iraq Yemen or even
Syria are on their way to becoming
satellites to Tehran moreover even
though their weapons date back to the
disco era the Iranian army has been able
to take on Saudi Arabia the United
States and even Israel however it is
within his own country that Ayatollah
Khamenei II is losing support don't
forget that in Iran a high proportion of
the population has studied at University
they are well educated and they don't
necessarily like living in Islamic
theocracy if to this you add the
economic crisis it's easy to understand
why the entire country has been
protesting since the beginning of 2018
lives like a God we the people live like
beggars not Gaza not Lebanon my life
only for Iran slogans from an Iranian
protest the song neither Gaza nor
Lebanon refers precisely to that double
standard that we're talking about while
Iranians barely have anything to eat the
Ayatollah regime continues to spend a
lot of money supporting Hamas in
Palestine or Hezbollah in Lebanon
not to mention that Iran itself is cut
off from the rest of the world so here
the question is why does Iran invest so
much in expanding its military influence
while it's people are on the verge of
famine are we facing the beginning of
the ends of the ayatollahs well let's
take a look at the history
[Music]
great she ate Empire in 1979 Ayatollah
Khomeini took control of the Iranian
government that is how the Islamic
theocracies that we know today began but
of course you probably already knew that
the question is what exactly is the
ayatollahs ideology is it just about
religion or is there another agenda well
to give you a better idea we could say
that the ayatollahs very similar to the
parodist s-- actually we could say that
Ayatollah Khomeini was to Iran what juan
domingo perón was to argentina in both
cases were talking about populist
movements that sold a revolution aimed
at the poor and what's more Khomeini
came to power helps by all kinds of
groups who had nothing to do with
religion for example local merchants who
had bazaars and didn't want to compete
with the Great Western chains to give
you an idea one of the first groups to
support Khomeini it was the Iranian
communists communist seek drops as soon
as he came to power and this is where
the second similarity with Peron arises
ideological fluidity in other words
these are my principles if they don't
prove popular enough well over got some
other ones from the outside the
ayatollahs may seem fanatic but
throughout this video you'll see how
they have changed alliances and
principles based on what was most
convenient at the time and what else
does a good populist need well yes that
would be a foreign enemy an antagonist
that shapes their political identity
in Iran's case its arch enemies are the
United States Israel and Saudi Arabia
and you might be thinking now well why
didn't they get along with Saudi Arabia
I mean they're both Muslim countries
well yes but in Saudi Arabia they are
Sunni Muslims and in Iran they are Shia
Muslims it's sort of like Protestants
and Catholics circa 1600 so what happens
when you have so many enemies well your
goal becomes ensuring their defeat and
extending your empire well that seems to
be the great dream of the ayatollahs
anyway in our domestic and foreign
policy we have set as our goal the
worldwide spread of the influence of
Islam we wish to cause the corrupt roots
of Zionism capitalism and communism to
wither throughout the world ayatollah
khomeini but although in seconds we
aren't just talking about ideology
Iran wants to control the Middle East as
a matter of survival you see in the 80s
Iran went to war with Saddam Hussein's
Iraq we're talking about a war that
killed more than 1 million Iranians and
displaced millions more a true bloodbath
that still has repercussions in the
country and by the way do you know who
they bought their weapons from to defend
themselves against Saddam Hussein well
yes that would be the United States but
isn't the United States the Empire of
Satan well that may be so but I mean hey
these are my principles if you don't
like them I have some other ones take
your pick
the truth is that the war against Iraq
taught the ayatollahs two very important
lessons one they needed to control the
region to survive and to their army
wasn't big enough to fight another
military power head-on there any way to
win a battle was with what we now call
asymmetric warfare that is guerrilla
warfare and using small targeted attacks
that managed to destabilize large armies
well back then in the 1980s Iran began
to specialize in this kind of warfare
the revolutionary Islamic Guard and
above all that could forces which we
hear so much about now true masters of
asymmetric warfare and I know where you
might be wondering okay this asymmetric
warfare may be fine when it comes to
defending yourself from an invasion but
can you conquer territories with
guerrilla warfare and how well let's
take a look at that right now
[Music]
fishermen make their day in troubled
waters we always say this on visual
politic power doesn't allow for vacuums
back in 2001 the United States began two
wars one against Iraq and one against
Afghanistan both countries they were
suffering under two terrible
dictatorships but at least it was clear
who was in charge after overthrowing
Saddam Hussein in Iraq and the Taliban
in Afghanistan
both countries who were thrown into a
power vacuum an a vacuum that wasn't
filled with Democratic politicians who
respected human rights but rather with
warlords who killed each other in order
to secure small areas of power
[Music]
in other words it was the perfect
situation for asymmetric warfare that
the Iranians had mastered so well and
that's exactly what happens according to
what we know from spy satellites back
then Iran built two training camps one
in L ba kua in Lebanon and another one
in Iran itself so you might be wondering
well what were these training camps for
well they were for local groups related
to Iran again all of this information
comes from US spy satellites and it may
not be totally accurate you can find
more information in their links that
will be even the description for why the
truth is that these centers have
shooting ranges and even circuits that
simulate real cities they have obstacles
fake walls and everything one needs to
recreate an urban guerrilla scene to
give you an idea Hezbollah guerrillas
trained at these camps yes the same ones
that got Israel to withdraw from Lebanon
in 2006 but that's not all members of
the Palestinian group Hamas they also
passed through here and you might be
thinking now well hold on a second Hamas
aren't they sunni muslims well yes they
are so then isn't iran supposed to be
against Sunni Islam well yes but as we
said before these are my principles if
you don't like them I have some other
ones basically it's in Iran's interest
to have a well on to mass that can face
Israel so for that reason the ayatollahs
have been able to put their differences
aside and train Sunni guerillas thanks
to this flexibility during the first
decade of the 2000s Iran was able to
expand its area of influence more than
ever yes by then they were already
suffering from the first wave of
economic sanctions but even though the
economy was starting to slump at home
things were going great further afield
but hold on because this is just the
beginning
you must pull out of Iraq after nearly
nine years of war exactly with the Obama
administration the United States
withdrew from Iraq this left an even
bigger power vacuum in that country so
what did Iran's you well it expanded its
training camps to give you an idea right
now the Ali
Aman camp which is on the outskirts of
Tehran is like the Harvard of asymmetric
warfare they of everything houses
mosques shooting ranges and even areas
to test explosives
thanks to this in recent years Iran has
been able to keep expanding its area of
influence in Iraq the Kurds forces have
given weapons to Shiite groups so that
they can fight Isis thanks to this help
Iran has become increasingly popular in
Iraq in fact the new Prime Minister will
likely be keeping very close ties to
Tehran and the same thing is happening
in Syria Iran support has been
instrumental in maintaining Bashar
al-assad's dictatorship the conclusion
well look at the map although Iran is
internationally isolated they now have
an entire corridor that leads them
straight to the Mediterranean while
always remaining on allied soil thought
about Yemen in the Yemen war the
official government supported by Saudi
Arabia were facing a huge range of rebel
groups one of these groups who are quite
small at the time whether who fear at
all they were supported by Iran today
they have Saudi Arabia against the ropes
in other words as far as geopolitics is
concerned Ayatollah Khamenei II and his
Kurds forces have been very effective at
the same time from an economic point of
view things do look pretty dire in Iran
and you know what you can't survive on
international political influence alone
so well what exactly is happening inside
Iran well let's take a look
enemy is inside Iran has the fourth
largest oil reserves in the world and
it's very good quality oil as well as
being easy and cheap to extract
basically with a shift in policies Iran
could be as rich as Saudi Arabia however
the truth is that they're actually
getting poorer why because no matter how
much oil they have almost nobody can buy
it
that's the effects of their current
economic sanctions today the main bars
of Iranian oil are China and India and
both countries have indicated that they
will buy less and less
[Music]
the same goes for other types of
investments European companies such as
Renault or the PSA group which includes
Persia and Citroen have had to stop all
of their projects in Iran why well this
is something we've covered in several
videos and we'll leave links to them in
the description as you can imagine by
not being able to sell anything
Iran's economy has collapsed they have
double-digit inflation
there's also high unemployment and there
are even food shortages all of this
explains why since 2018 there have been
regular protests throughout the country
but without a doubt the peak of these
protests came in November of 2009 tea
[Music]
Ronn abruptly raises fuel prices and
protests erupt for years Iran has
subsidized gas prices that way even if
the prices of other commodities rose
Iranians could count on filling their
gas tanks for very little money without
an income the government can no longer
subsidize gas so overnight Tehran
announced a 50 percent rise in gas
prices and that was the last straw
every major Iranian city was filled with
protesters and how did the government
react what do you think I had her come
in any set he could have been flexible
right he could have said okay these are
my principles but if you don't like them
I have others but it didn't play out
like that according to Amnesty
International the police killed more
than 200 people to suppress the protests
and according to some estimates the
figure could have been higher than a
thousand people but all of this happens
before January the 3rd 2020 which is the
day this
[Applause]
[Music]
Qasem Soleimani Trump since us killed a
monster
exactly Salah moniz death was a blow to
the very core of the ayatollahs regime
but it also helped their cause
now suddenly at a martyr suddenly the
streets of Tehran were again filled with
people but this time they weren't
protests against the government was
quite the opposite
thousands of people showed their support
in the fight against that little Satan
who represented the United States from
Ayatollah Khomeini's point of view this
was a big boost for his propaganda and
then there was a bit of a slip
[Music]
[Applause]
iran says it unintentionally shot down a
Ukrainian airliner in a nutshell the
story goes like this
five days after salim arnis
assassination all of iran was on high
alert suddenly a passenger plane took
off from Tehran Airport from a nearby
military base they thought it was an
enemy plane and they launched a missile
the results 176 innocent people lost
their lives among them 82 Iranians that
is Iran wanted to respond to an attack
from the United States and instead they
ended up killing their own citizens and
not only that many sources indicate that
the Iranian government itself tried to
hide the Army's responsibility the truth
is that the whole world learned about
these events because several videos
clearly showed a missile hitting the
plane I mean come on even if they wanted
to they couldn't hide it in other words
the comparison with true noble is now
evident it was a self-imposed disaster
and as you can imagine thousands of
Iranians once again returned to the
streets
brain Ian's protests for third day over
downed airliner amid reports of gunfire
by security forces and so how is ayat
Ola Khamenei you reacting is he finally
willing to show the flexibility that is
so well known for abroad well no it
seems not
Iran's constitutional watchdog has
barred thousands of people from running
in next month's parliamentary elections
including 90 current lawmakers
interestingly those 90 deputies who have
just been cast out of Parliament's
belong to Iran's moderate wing that is
they are the ones that support the
regime the least in other words the
Iranian regime is having a bad time and
it's only solution right now is to push
forward so now here's a question for you
do you think we're going to see a regime
change in Iran anytime soon do you think
that a leader will emerge who can
relieve this discontent or will
Ayatollah Khamenei be able to hold on to
power
I'll leave us your answer in the
comments and as always please don't
forget that we publish brand new videos
every week so subscribe to visual
politic click on the bells so you don't
miss any updates and if you like this
video please do give it a thumbs up and
I'll see you in the next one if you want
to learn more about politics and world
affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider @ww
re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
you